There are many different signs in the street.
Right. They tell us lots of things.
Signs tell us what to do and what not to do.
Look at this. This sign tells us how fast we can go.
What else do you see?
This sign warns us about animals on the road.
And that sign tells us to drive slowly on winding roads.
Signs are everywhere and they tell us lots of things.
Signs are on posts and on buildings.
Signs are everywhere.
Signs are in windows and on doors.
They hang above streets.
Signs tell us when to walk and when not to walk.
Signs tell us how far to go and how fast we can go.
Signs warn us about children playing and animals on the road.
Signs tell us to drive slowly on winding roads.
People make signs for sales and for lost animals.
What, what, what, what other things do we make signs for?